>> Jason: DEMOCRATS THINK THE
GOVERNMENT KNOWS BEST WHEN IT
COMES TO YOUR KIDS' EDUCATION
PEER PRESIDENT BIDEN BROILING OF
CONCERN TO PARENTS ABOUT WHAT HE
JUST SAID ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE IN
CHARGE OF THE CLASSROOM.
>> THERE TOO MANY PEOPLE TRYING
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS AND
BANNED BOOKS, EVEN MATH BOOKS.
DID YOU EVER THINK MAYBE YOUR
YOUNGER TEACHERS, DID YOU EVER
THINK YOU WOULD BE TEACHING AND
BE WORRIED ABOUT BOOK BURNING
AND BANNING BOOKS?
ALL BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT
SOMEBODY'S POLITICAL AGENDA.
THEY ARE ALL OUR CHILDREN AND
THE REASON YOU WERE THE TEACHERS
OF THE YEAR IS BECAUSE YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT.
>> Jason: AND REMEMBER THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN BLUE
STATES SAID THEY NEEDED TO
BATTLE COVID?
TURNS OUT NEW YORK, ILLINOIS,
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES USE
SOME OF THAT MONEY TO PUSH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY LESSON
PLANS.
NOT ALL THE MONEY WENT TO WHERE
THEY SAID IT WAS GOING TO GO BUT
I THINK BEING A LITTLE TONE-DEAF
HERE, AS THE PRESIDENTIAL'S
FALLING INTO THE SAME PATTERNS
THAT TERRY McAULIFFE FELL INTO
ENDS THAT THEY ARE OUR KIDS, NOT
YOUR KIDS?
>> Dana: THERE HAVE BEEN
WARNING SIDES, DON'T STEP ON
THAT PARTICULAR RACE, SORRY, NOT
THAT ONE EITHER.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT GLENN
YOUNGKIN GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA,
MAYBE HE WILL RUN FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2024 PRESIDENT TRUMP DECIDES
NOT TO RUN BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
BROUGHT VIRGINIA TO THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE, THIS VERY
ISSUE.
IF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO MAKE
THESE ARGUMENTS HE HAS TO DO IT
IN A MORE WHOLESOME WAY.
HE CAN'T HAVE A COMMENT LIKE
THIS THAT IS GOING TO GET CUT,
THIS IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN,
IT'S GOING TO BE CUT, SO YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE BEING
VERY CLEAR IF THAT IS NOT WHAT
YOU MEANT.
ON THE MONEY BEING SPENT ON CRT
AND NOT OTHER THINGS, I AM MAD
ABOUT IT, I THINK TAXPAYER
SHOULD BE MAD ABOUT.
ONE THING IS WE HAVE TO MAKE
CONGRESS TO BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HOW THIS MONEY IS GOING TO
BE SPENT.
IF YOU CONTROL THE PURSE STRINGS
THEN YOU CAN CONTROL HOW PEOPLE
SPEND AND THAT INCLUDED THE PPE
MONEY, $500 MILLION IN FRAUD?
FOR THE PPE LOANS AND THEN YOU
HAVE THIS MONEY THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO TO SCHOOL SO WE
CAN IMPROVE THE VENTILATION
SYSTEM AND THEY SPENT IT ON
THIS?
I GET WHY PARENTS ARE MAD.
>> $122 BILLION WENT TO THESE
GOALS SO THEY COULD REOPEN AND
CLEAN OUT THE AIR DUCTS AND HAVE
THE MASTIC DIVIDERS AND
THOSE THINGS AND THEY ARE DOING
THE VERY THING RILING UP SO MANY
PARENTS, WHY PARENTS ARE
LEAVING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION COULD CONTINUE TO
BE SO INCREDIBLY TONE-DEAF.
>> Jessica: AM INTERESTED IN
ACTUALLY SEEING THE LINES COMING
HERE IS $1 AND THIS IS EXACTLY
WHERE IT WENT TO.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO GO TO THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM AND THERE'S GOOD
REASON TO THINK THE CURRICULUM
THAT EMPLOYS SOME DEGREE OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, YOU ARE
USING IT TO BOLSTER HER
FACILITIES AND PAY TEACHERS AND
KEEP CLASSROOMS CLEAN AND
WHATEVER THAT I GUESS I COULD
TECHNICALLY GO TO THAT BUT THAT
WAS CLEARLY NOT THE INTENTION
WHEN THAT MONEY WAS ALLOCATED TO
THOSE TEN STATES.
IN TERMS OF BIDEN'S COMMENT, I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT HE
WAS TRYING TO SAY AND I DON'T
THINK IT WAS ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
WHAT TERRY McAULIFFE SAID,
WHICH IS THAT PARENTS HAVE NO
ROLE IN WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
TEACHERS OR WHAT GOES ON IN THE
CLASSROOM.
BIDEN WAS MAKING THE POINT THAT
YOU AS PARENTS WOULD ACTUALLY
WANT TEACHERS TO FEEL THE SAME
WAY THAT YOU DO ABOUT YOUR KIDS.
YOU CARE FOR THEM, TO BE
NURTURING THEM AND TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEM AND
PROVIDING A GREAT SERVICE.
I DON'T THINK IT IS THE SAME
THING BUT EVERYTHING GETS CUT
UP, EVERYTHING IS GOING IN AN AD
AND THAT IS NOT SOMETHING WE CAN
AFFORD.
THERE WAS A BIG
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" PIECE
WHERE HE INTERVIEWED A
DEMOCRATIC VOTER IN NEW JERSEY,
WHO DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE
GOING TO VOTE FOR BECAUSE OF
MASKING KIDS IN SCHOOLS, AND
THEY ARE JUST SAYING, WAIT, I
HAVE TO -- SORRY, ANYWAY.
>> Jason: BUT THIS IS PART OF
THE POINT, JUDGE.
LOOK UP A BIDEN ACTUALLY SAID.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES COME HE DOESN'T
GET A PASS BY SAYING, I MEANT
THIS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT HE
SAID, THE CHILDREN ARE HOURS
WHEN THEY ARE IN THE CLASSROOM.
THEY ARE NOT SOMEBODY ELSE'S
CHILDREN.
WRONG.
MY CHILD IS MY CHILD, WHETHER MY
CHILD IS AT HOME OR IN THE
CLASSROOM.
THEY ARE NOT YOUR CHILDREN, THEY
ARE ALWAYS MY CHILDREN, I GIVE
YOU THE RIGHT TO HAVE THEM IN
THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE I ELECTED
TO ALLOW THEM IN THE CLASSROOM.
I LIKED TO HAVE THEM TAUGHT IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL, AND I FIND THIS
SO INCREDIBLE THAT BIDEN IS
SAYING THAT THE TEACHERS ARE
REALLY THE VICTIMS HERE.
TEACHERS ARE BEING UNFAIRLY
TARGETED, THAT IS A QUOTE FROM
BIDEN, IN THE CULTURE WARS.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THE TEACHERS ARE THE ONES WHO
SAID THE PARENTS WERE THE
TERRORISTS AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FBI WITH
IT.
HERE IS WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE
THE BOTTOM LINE, THAT THIS IS A
NEW WORLD ORDER.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BRING THE
CHILDREN INTO PART OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE OURS, WE ARE GOING TO
DECIDE WHAT TO TEACH THEM AND
NEW PARENTS, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
TELL YOU ABOUT IT BUT IF YOU
FIND OUT ABOUT IT, IT IS STILL
NONE OF YOUR BUSINESS.
IS THE MESSAGE.
WE PAY THE TEACHERS 'SALARY, WE
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE PRODUCTS,
WHICH IS A CHILD AND WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DECIDE WHETHER TO SEND
OUR CHILD TO YOUR SCHOOL OR
PRIVATE SCHOOL OR TO TEACH THEM
AT HOME, AND CUT OUT THE CRAP,
THEY ARE OUR CHILDREN AND NOBODY
ELSE'S.
STOP, IT IS ABSURD.
>> Greg: CUSTODIAL
INTERFERENCE!
I'M USING THAT TONIGHT ON MY
SHOW.
THERE ARE GREAT TEACHERS BUT
BECAUSE OF THE TEACHER UNION
LEADERSHIP, THE ZOOM MEETINGS,
THEY AREN'T WELL REPRESENTED
ANYMORE.
WE ONLY HEAR FROM THE CRAZY
TEACHERS AND AGAIN, THIS IS
ANOTHER ARENA WHERE IT WOKISM
HAS REALLY KIND OF LOOTED AND
POISONED A THING THAT WE USED TO
LOVE.
WHEN I WAS A KID, YOU THOUGHT
YOUR TEACHERS WERE MAGICAL,
RIGHT?
THEY TAUGHT YOU CURSIVE
HANDWRITING, THEY TREATED YOU
LIKE THEY WERE YOUR KIDS, BUT
NOW, WHO IS MAJORING IN
EDUCATION, ARE THESE VERY
AGGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS WHO ARE
OBSESSIVE ABOUT IDENTITY AND
RADICALISM AND I COULD
UNDERSTAND CONCERN IF BIDEN WAS
TALKING ABOUT IF THE CHILDREN
WERE COMING FROM BROKEN HOMES
ARE REALLY BAD HOMES.
MAYBE THERE WERE NO PARENTS, BUT
ASSUMING THAT ALL CHILDREN ARE
PROBLEM CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY
DON'T LIKE THE PARENTS AND THE
MORE OPPRESSIVE THEY ARE SEEN BY
LIBERAL EDUCATORS, SO THEY DON'T
LIKE THE CONFLICT THAT THE
PARENTS ARE GIVING, SO IN FACT,
THEY STARTED THE CULTURE WAR.
IT WASN'T FOR THE PARENTS.
THE KIDS ARE THE CANNON FODDER.
>> Jason: I AM STILL STUCK ON
CUSTODIA